hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen hier heute meine damen und
herren zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal mit samen die guides aus ganz
deutschland und eu west was aus
deutschland und egoist und eu west auf
allem aus allen eigentlich aus der
ganzen universität ja herzlich
willkommen damit meine damen und herren
hier zum heutigen video und zwar sieht
es bereits im titel eingeblendet und
zwar reagieren wir beiden heute ist das
neue lied von katja namens wer bist du
das ding ist das ist jetzt seit mehr als
einer woche draußen und das hat gerade
mal 1,6 millionen aufrufe und deshalb so
wenig eigentlich für sein rap video ihre
anderen lieder haben auf jeden fall viel
mehr views gemacht deswegen ich weiß
nicht ob sie damit eventuell eine andere
richtung gegangen ist dass leute sich
dachten oh das ist gar nicht so gutes
klicken wir uns nicht ob ich an prozent
von ihr da gibst mir das war locker ein
monat bei dior wo also die wir auf jeden
fall ein kranker ohrwurm
das hatte ich auch drauf reagiert da hat
er mir noch nicht die einnahmen weg
gestrichen
aber bei meiner letzten action auf ihr
letztes lied habe ich leider keinen
einzigen cent verdient unser stunden
lang daran das ist erst mal werbung für
ihr album was bald kommt in drei monaten
kann das jetzt schon selbst die werbung
macht das wie elf sekunden bisher ist
nur werbung für ihr neues album
aber jeder guckt jeder murr kreis gut
selber eine frage
sie ist ja wirklich auf der straße hatte
kein wirklich nichts an ich oder hat
diese hautfarbe das lies ich nichts
unterwäsche an ich glaube die leute ich
komplett nackt rum oder ok wo ich glaube
sie wirklich nackt ich was steht oder
sie hat hier so was dran geklebt genau
hier die linke
hier steht irgendwie es juckt mich nicht
oder ist jugend mich schauen wir weiter
[Musik]
der sound hat sich gar nicht so schlecht
ja und das videos auch kraß gemacht also
auch dass hier mit diesem leuchten und
so und die sieht muss man sagen die sind
auch nicht hardcore hässlich aussehen
aber sehr wahrscheinlich sagen uns
kassel sid vom gesicht ja auch gar
keinen fall aber als 13.000 tonnen
make-up drin
ich hab nur letztes mal dieses foto hier
von ihren weg da war sie ungeschminkt
das war schon nicht so schön aus ich
muss halt überlegen
so sieht sie ungeschminkt aus und
geschminkt sie dann so aus dass halt ja
aber fast jeder mensch sieht geschminkt
aus also doch nicht jeder ist wenn die
sexy ist auf die ganze deutsche welle
das war ja zu lustig
also ich muss auch sagen ich höre
eigentlich absolut keinen deutschland
eigentlich wegen sowas weil alles nur
noch auto tuning und einfach nur nackt
und karin und keine ahnung was ich sagen
muss überlegt mir dagegen federn ja was
sagen musst dir also lang ist mir doch
die wahrheit warum aber ich finde dass
mein gott ich würde mit kopfhörern
schenkten sogar so hören ich finde das
hört sich nicht schlecht an
das heißt die halter weiter auf
deutschland junge also ich würde jetzt
nicht kopfhörer rein machen und das so
hören aber was ich sagen wollte ist dass
es von der kompletten mache hat auf
jeden fall sehr professionell wirkt
herbst auf jeden fall wieder einen
schritt nach vorne vom letzten video das
habe ich auch bei ihren bisherigen
liedern immer gesagt dass es nicht so
schlecht ist wie jetzt beispielsweise
bibi die da irgendwie über boxing
sondern sie hat schon talent das ganze
angeht also kannst du siehst gutes team
hinter dir muss man ehrlich sagen aber
auch platz gemacht auch hier mit der
ganzen ausleuchtung und hier bällebad
ist und coole ideen dann muss allerdings
wieder sagen es geht absolut keinen sinn
also es ist jetzt nicht so der musik um
und sexuell das bewegt die menschen und
das regt die an nachzudenken über
umweltschutz und genial und blau sondern
ich bin boss der bosse ja so wie
eigentlich jeder ist jeder sagte ich bin
boskovic es geht nur um ihr effekt jetzt
geht darum dass die bosse +18 eigentlich
auch in dem video
also entweder streicht mit katja die
einnahmen wegen copyright oder youtube
als +18 ist ja ich werde vielleicht
einfach in so ein ding eingepasst sich
um ein puzzle gar nicht mal reinpassen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
schreibt man die kommen darauf andere
letztes live aufgelegt bei mir in der
wohnung hier ein foto von seinem
auftritt gegen bubba megabyte
aber die anderen auch allen akten
um auf die dass katja auf einmal die
dreadlocks negativ aus die komplett
anderer mensch die hatten ein loch hat
sehen so make up artist und keine ahnung
was am set
sie sagt immer schießt boss ja aber wo
ist die bob wieso die ganze zeit sagt
ich wie die typen läuft danach dom
präsentiert jetzt wer sie einfach nur
billig weiß vielleicht hätte ich das
nicht richtig weil ich kein mädel bin
oder mich kein deutschland oder und so
aber war die kohle hat geld denkt boss
pitt hat die wirklich kohle weil ich hab
mal es ist keines ihrer videos ist werbe
freundlich in der nicht reicher das
könntest du den niemand so leisten so
eine heftiges musikvideo zu drehen wir
halt im hintergrund links und major
label stehen irgendwie warner music oder
universe oder keine ahnung was und die
pumpen aber wahrscheinlich ordentlich
geld haben weil sie wissen ja die ganzen
keine ahnung was kinder die schauen sich
das an uns weiter und so fort aber ich
finde es sehr bedenklich weil die leute
die das hier konsumieren die sind ja
junger und sie praktiziert ja und zeigt
um das coole image wenn meine post ein
perfekt eure klamotten nackt sein wenn
so ein schritt weiter denkweise erklärt
den baum beschreibt er wird besser
verstehen als ich und jetzt plötzlich in
die tennis
sie sind wieder komplett anders aus ich
finde sie für ihn david und loredana ich
kenne könnte die würden die alle
zusammen darf nicht könnt ihr die nicht
auseinanderhalten wege auch wenn die
singen können nicht auseinanderhalten
ich finde diesen alle vom see alle ja
von der richtung sollen die sechser
jacken sich so ein fettes make up team
hinter stände und blabla würde ich
denken dies ein hübsches mädchen
aber wenn man dann checkt okay das ist
katja krawitz und sie sich eigentlich so
aus und macht das um das dann will ich
mich ja denkt okay
es hat sich die ganze zeit stoppen
aber ich hätte das sieht doch blablabla
genannt si net das sieht wer bist du
also eins davon absolut nichts realtech
nichts gar nichts mit dem text bisher zu
tun
sie will die ganze zeit im refrain bla
bla bla bla und das ist das was im kopf
hängen bleibt dieses klar blablabla
ich hätte das safe blablabla genannt
jetzt sagt sie werde suchen zum ersten
mal so richtig nicht nur jetzt kommen
noch ein paar szenen von seeed unnormal
aus ja und das war es was man ja so las
ich sagen muss es hört sie hat sich auf
jeden fall gesteigert und ich sag ja
immer es ist ihre sache was sie aus
ihrem leben macht ich hasse es wenn
leute sagen ja ich bin boss bildschirm
wer bist du dann denkt man sich so
bruder was sich besonderes ding ist was
mir bisher noch gar nicht so wirklich
gesagt haben oder was mir auch jetzt
gerade das aufgefallen ist das lied ist
bei zwei minuten 39 zu ende und die
ersten 20 sekunden weil nur werbung
das lied geht quasi zwei minuten da
merkt man halt wie wenig inhalt und text
et cetera da drin steckt ja
wahrscheinlich das ganze lied und das
ganze video an einem tag produziert dann
überlege ich mir so entschieden habe ich
letztens diese doku auf apple music
gesehen alter der vier wochen irgendwo
in der totalen ballerei mit zehn pro
user nun hat dabei nur ein lied gemacht
was natürlich klar milliarden mal abgeht
und dann noch für kinofilme von omikron
trotz aber nie dann merkt halt wieder wo
die unterschiede aber ich glaube das
kann ja auch gar nicht in diese richtung
irgendwie entschieden oder pop was
überall läuft gehen will sondern einfach
nur wirklich ihr image so ein bisschen
ausschlachten
wie bereits gesagt also wir beide kennen
hat ja nicht persönlich habe sie auch
noch nie gesehen klar oliver dirr
gesprochen nicht mal in echt gesehen
also ich weiß auch nicht ob sie
vielleicht wirklich so ungeschminkt so
aussieht oder geschminkt so oder keine
ahnung was aber ich habe von vielen
leuten gehört dass sie tatsächlich sehr
korrekt drauf sein soll
also freunde von mir videos mit der
gedrehten dies total nett und so
deswegen
wir trinken schreibt mal unter katjas
instagram bilder dass sie in den podcast
kommen soll wurde das wird so spaß dass
ich das heute wieder ist allerdings ob
meine lieben freunde sehr viele von euch
am unter unsere letzte hilfe reaktion
geschrieben sie sehr viele leute haben
auf jeden fall unter die letzte hilfe
direkt schon von anderen mir geschrieben
dass wir unbedingt mal auf das neue lied
von katja reagieren sollen namens mehr
bistum das haben wir jetzt hier mit
heute getan
ich würde sagen ich gebe dem ganzen lied
7 von 10 punkten um es kurz zu begründen
ich find es alles sehr professionell
drum rum und sie hört sich auch nicht an
er habe nichts sagen es hört sich
professionell an alles aber wegen der
message und weil das sie zu kurzes und
kein inhalt und sofort gespannt was ihn
im jahr kommt dass wir heute auf jeden
fall gefallen hat dass auch nicht einen
daumen hoch unter dem video ihr da
schreibt uns gerne und in die kommentare
das neue lied von katja schon gehört
habt beziehungsweise was ihr davon
haltet genau das lied ist auf jeden fall
auch in der beschreibung verlinkt das
heißt wer bist du abonniert genau main
kanal unter dem million sandra lädt
jetzt auch blogs hoch deswegen da könnt
ihr auch gerne vorbeischauen
[Musik]